In the tablet wire frames,
when a list item is selected,
it shows this blue
activated state background.
This can be done by setting
the background of the list item to be
a state drawable.
We can look at the documentation for
this StateListDrawable,
which is linked below.
Essentially, a StateListDrawable allows
you to specify different drawables
based on the state of the view.
We provide you a code for
the StateListDrawable.
Drop it in by creating a drawable
folder under the res directory.
When set as the background of a list
item, we see that the background is just
transparent by default such
as this today lay out here.
When the view is pressed,
then we see a grey background.
When the view is activated,
then we see this blue color.
This is also indicating that it's
the selected item in the two pane mode.
We also have a second version
of the touch_selector file for
Lollipop devices and above.
This is saved in
the drawable-v21 folder.
Set on platforms API level 21 and
above, it will use this
version of the touch_selector.
On older devices it will fall back
to the touch_selector in the base
drawable folder.
One of the main principles of material
design is responsive interaction.
One way to accomplish this is that
when a user touches a device,
the device will acknowledge
the interaction, and
a ripple will radiate out
from the touch point.
This is done with a ripple drawable.
You can add a ripple element in
your state list drawable xml.
For the v21 touch selector, it's the
same except that for the pressed state,
we have a ripple drawable with
a grey color for touch feedback.
And on a Lollypop device,
you can see the ripple.
In the list item layout, we set the
background to be this touch_selector.
We do the same for
the list_item_forecast_today layout.
Back in the touch_selector file, I want
to note that there's some colors here.
The @android color notation is for
a framework defined color.
The other colors are ones that we
defined in the colors.xml file.
This file is located in
the Values folder of your app.
It's useful to store colors
in a central location
if you need a reference colors
multiple times in your app.
As a hint.
to make a list item show its activated
state, you can look at the documentation
for the XML attribute choiceMode for
the ListView.
Once you find the right attribute,
you'll realize that you want different
behavior for
one pane versus two pane mode.
While you could change the behaviour
programatically in the Java code,
we'd like you to do it purely via
the resource XML files using a style.
Read this doc to learn about how
styles can be defined in XML.
And use what you learned earlier about
defining alternative resources for
different size devices.
In general, styles are a way that
you can group together attributes
for a view.
For example, these text attributes
are replaced by this style CodeFont.
The CodeFont style is defined
in the styles.xml file
located in the Values folder.
You can also have styles inherit other
styles by specifying the parent.
There are a couple of other examples
you can check out on this page.
This is what the app should
look like when you're done.
In one pane mode,
we don't see the activated state.
But there's still the regular
press state with the ripple and
then it goes away